[Music]
the original creation of the turtles
came out of love passion in a late night
out of goofiness
we did this drawing of a turtle standing
upright with a mask on nunchucks rap to
his arms and I put it on a piece of desk
and I said this is going to be the next
big thing in Ninja Turtle
[Music]
the Animated Series came out in 1987
when I was five years old the live
action movie came out in 1990. I was
eight it was like perfectly geared
towards someone my age Ninja Turtles did
something that all of us have been
obsessed with ever since we were kids I
remember being four years old and
wanting all of the toys action figures
cartoons the bed sheets I was just kind
of obsessed with them I started taking
karate probably because of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles how much love was
put into their designs and their props
my dad bought me nunchucks because of
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles package
art and everything about it was like
funny and weird and told a story
they called us and said would you guys
ever be interested in working on the
Teenage Ninja Turtles did we play it
cool at all or no no
if we can approach it through this
teenage lens
really lean into like a coming-of-age
version of it and they said yes like a
brother Jeff was willing to say like we
have to make this look and feel totally
different he was like What if it's
animated by teenagers so to speak we put
so much work into the visuals into the
artwork the style is perfect for this
it's almost like an underground comic it
reminds me a lot of the original stuff
that Peter and I did
it's you and your buddies it's you and
your brothers it's you and your sister
and your brother I think a lot of people
can relate to kind of feeling like an
outsider at times
this desire to fit in to be accepted
it's one of the most essential emotions
the fans are insanely awesome whether it
be I love the turtle so much I wore the
same Halloween costume for three years
in a row or I had a really tough
childhood and the turtles helped me get
through that and that's when it hits you
emotionally
wanting to create wanting to tell your
own stories and then actually having it
happen it's a dream and it happened I
love the Ninja Turtles it was like the
first thing I was ever a fan of it's fun
and exciting
here I am 61 years old and I'm still
getting up and drawing Comics Turtles
every day
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]